you walk into a bakery and you get a
free sample because they want to sell
you a muffin that makes sense but you
you go online and use a website for free
and there's nothing to sell you that
doesn't make sense so I think free is a
great model as long as you have
something to sell also free should be an
incentive we like to say you should be
emulating drug dealers basically you
know drug dealers give you a little
sprinkle or a little taste and get you
hooked and then you buy from them they
don't just give you more free drugs all
day you buy something from them so we're
a big fan of emulating drug dealers
basically or bakeries that might be a
better way to put it but anyway that
model works but in the open-source world
that's kind of a different thing there's
some companies that open source software
and then sell support on top of it so
that's one way to make money off
open-source for us we think that the
open source thing works for us because
first of all the products better and we
get to use rails and so if other people
are improving it that's good for us we
can use that in our pay products
secondly whenever people mention rails
they mention 37signals or they mentioned
Basecamp or high-rise or us in some way
and that indirectly benefits us as well
so that's kind of the guiding principle
for us so some stuffs free most us pay
well ads do make sense in some cases but
people you know look at Google and they
go well Google's making billions on ads
they're putting as necessary salts like
we should put ads next to everything too
because it worked for Google well it
works for Google because if you think
about it like you're going to Google to
search for something you want to find
something and advertisers then pitching
their wares that are relevant makes
sense because I'm looking to find
something and they have something for me
that I could find and use that makes
sense but throwing ads up alongside
content that doesn't I'm not going there
to find a search to buy something I'm
just going to read an article that
doesn't work as well and so you see a
lot of company and software like if I'm
using software to do something I'm not
using software to do something to find
an ad I'm using software to do something
to do something so it works for Google's
model because that's what I'm going
there to do is to discover it it learns
to purchase something but in most cases
if that's not the case I don't think ads
work all that well unless you have a
tremendous amount of traffic and that's
really really really hard there's also a
problem with the disconnect between ads
and users my belief is that the you can
build a better business if the people
who use your product or the same people
who pay for your product in the ad that
ad supported model the people who pay
for your product are enough people use
it people pay for the advertisers and
the people who use it are the users and
there's a disconnect so who are you who
are you building it for who do you
really have to make happy you know in
many cases it ends up being the
advertisers which is why you see a lot
of new sites especially they're just ads
everywhere and that's a pretty crappy
experience I think so I'm not a big fan
of that model I think it you know some
people can make it work but I'm not a
big fan of it and I think the default
idea that we'll just put ads on it
that's what we'll support we'll put ads
on it is a terrible idea and it's much
much much easier to actually get people
to pay for your product or your content
or whatever then it is to throw ads up
and last thing I'll say about this is
that putting a price on something forces
you to make it good and that is like
those are the constraints you need on
you a force that forces you to make
something good because if something is
free and ad-supported doesn't really
have to be that good it's free I'll use
it it's free I don't care
but the moment I start paying you for it
that's the moment it forces you to be
good and give me a service that's
paying for and that to me is the right
pressure to have on a company
I like some of the more interesting like
one of the things I like today is
there's a company called Twilio
I think that's how they're pronounced
pronounced Twi Li oh and they are
basically kind of a new type of company
that's selling I don't want to get
technical but selling it like API access
basically what they let you do is they
let you create conference calls and or
voicemail systems or phone trees with
really simple programming language with
a really simple programming language and
what they do is they kind of sit in
between you so if I'm a company that
wants to make a conference calling
system I might use their technology and
then I might pay per minute for their
technology instead of like subscribing
to them on a monthly basis or whatever I
pay as I go and I think that model is
pretty interesting it's similar the way
Amazon is doing with Amazon Web Services
where I can rent a server by the minute
you know instead of having a bio server
or pay up front so I like this like pay
per true use thing I like that model a
lot so I think that's kind of a cool
innovation that's coming up right now
and I think that those are interesting
companies to watch